i i'm i haven't thought about it
i haven't had any discussions with
christopher about
any of this i mean my job is to get us
ready for the next game so that's what
i'm gonna worry about
um
are you hopeful that these last two
weeks will have an impact on ownership's
decision
it's once again it's something i can't
worry about i i gotta i gotta focus on
getting us ready for the next one
you know i i am so used to seeing it now
that it doesn't register anymore but
it's the adam gase
shorter seesaw how he always stands
like that and then it'll go like that
it's never
it's never level it's always it's always
one way or the other anyway
uh we'll see what happens with adam gase
after week 17.
they can finish with three straight wins
and and again joe douglas
who by all accounts is safe has made it
clear that
he believes in adam gase and they didn't
fire him at the bye week when they were
winless so sometimes the evidence is
hiding
in plain sight and people just don't
want to see it all right trivia question
time as we get ready for goats in a bad
way for week 16.
josh allen chris became last night the
second quarterback
ever to throw four touchdowns and zero
interceptions
in a game at gillette stadium visiting
team quarterback second one to do it
who was the first wow that is a well
okay so we're talking about the last 20
years of football really right because
that's
2002. yeah man i know not many games
where the patriots give up four
touchdown passes and no picks no that's
where
it's like i i i i'm just don't this is
not the answer yet i you know does sh
i know if desean watson and russell
wilson had great games there
i can remember them i'm gonna go with
peyton manning though i feel like there
was a sunday night game where he tore it
up
uh damn in like 2006. i was going to
give you a hint if i give you this hint
let me see if you can get it yeah it was
a season opening game
was it alex smith and the kansas city
chiefs yeah there you go dammit yeah i
did not think of that does it not
register in my brain charlie
check down did not register in my brain
for four touchdowns against
the patriots just to prove
that i am not the grinch control room
i'm gonna give you the first pick for
getting it right when i gave you the
hint because that was a difficult
question wow are you really
going to do that for me then yeah go
ahead what the hell i mean we're just
it's well not like it's not if there was
money riding on this or something i
wouldn't but
we're just having fun and we're just bam
there he is yeah we're just having fun
there wow wow
go ahead and go okay here we go take a
pic i think i got to go with the corner
from the las vegas raiders uh damon
arnett
the the rookie from ohio state you know
that play in itself hey listen we can
bring
blame the whole defensive staff for the
raiders maybe they didn't communicate
the right way or how he should play it i
don't know but
they're playing cover two in cover two
yeah you're responsible for the flat if
somebody's in the flat
but if nobody's in the flat you got to
go deep and of course there's 12 seconds
left who gives a damn about the flat
let him throw it five six yards into the
flat then there'll be
six seconds left and they gotta throw a
75-yard hail mary
that to me was just the goat of the
weekend right there the fact that they
let
ryan fitzpatrick make that throw to have
somebody that open and then of course
the
face mask penalty on top of it who i
can't even remember who grabbed his face
mask off the top of my head but
uh rookie mistake big time in a big way
for damon uh damon arnett
see i had gruden down as my goat for the
raiders because he said i take full
responsibility it's easy to take full
responsibility when you're never going
to get fired it's beautiful
it's a beautiful thing you can take
responsibility for everything that has
gone wrong in the entire world when you
know you're not getting fired for it so
if gruden wants a responsibility he gets
it that's not my pick though i'll i'll
defer to yours of damon arnett
mine is dwayne haskins we've already
spent time talking about him i mean he
got fired
it's so obvious he was a goat in a bad
way coming out of sunday that he got
fired he got cut with guaranteed money
left on his contract
and it's for basically the whole body of
work from everything that happened
after the last week's game until the the
aftermath of sunday's
loss the the refusal to submit to the
media obligation and he finally did it
kicking and screaming and whatever it
was happened was the straw that broke
the camel's back and he's out of a job
and
he didn't play very well either and
that's that dwayne haskins is my pick
yeah i i mean it's i'm with you i i
didn't pick them just because i feel
i put them on my list just because i
feel like we talked about it so much and
it's just it's
it's a tough situation but man not a
good look certainly
for him and uh best of luck for him in
the future
all right you know gotta go to atlanta
for this one
you know it it hurts me but uh young who
young hoku
right i hope i said that right way young
way young way
young way was wrong way sorry young wei
ku
who's from a town over from where i grew
up
ridgewood new jersey been phenomenal all
year
going to the pro bowl man end of the
game
17-14 you go it's lined up perfect
they're we're going to overtime
the chiefs and the falcons and young way
misses really probably one of the
easiest
three points he had all all year you
know very makeable field goal
misses it off to the right and just kind
of a
a basic theme for the falcons all year
just
man find a way to mess it up can't
figure it out whatever whether it's that
play todd gurley falling at the one
you know uh or not falling at the one
ryan
matt ryan throwing picks a few weeks ago
against the chargers it just always
seems something happens to the falcons
but he's the goat for me this week
i still don't know what that kick did is
that crazy
because it's it's heading right down the
middle
and then it takes this turn right i mean
like this
wind came out of nowhere just but uh
yeah i felt bad for him and
you know i think the announcers kind of
liked to the the jinx thing like they
were talking about who was the kicker
they said oh it was justin tucker yeah
never misses never misses never misses
never misses anything that was joe
buckland
they're like we're not gonna jinx them
yeah we're not going to jinx him and he
misses it and then
oh he's pro bowl right here and then see
you later
okay amazing next one for me um
[Music]
mike zimmer um
but he picked gruden and now he's going
to zimmer
i got i got listen that was
humiliating embarrassing
devastating to give up 52 points i mean
two historic events first of all
the first time the vikings gave up 50
points since the disastrous les
steckel lost season of 1984 when they
were beaten by the 49ers 51-7
the most points surrendered by the team
since 1963 for crying out loud
when the cardinals scored 56 on them
only the fourth time
in 60 years of football they gave up 50
or more points
and and they gave up six touchdowns to
alvin kamara
and i don't care how many of your guys
are injured
why let's get this is the theme of the
segment would you
stop it please nicole stop it
but look it was embarrassing
it was humiliating and and you know you
can
i think zimmer said yesterday uh i i
need to do better
yeah you do need to do better but again
and let me just rew i know we're running
out of time
remember what i said after the 2019
season what did i say chris all these
guys up for extension yeah
i say the vikings should do what did i
say they should do don't extend any of
them yeah
let them all play out their contracts or
coach out their contracts or general
manager out their contracts and if they
don't get it done this year
you have a clean slate you can do
whatever you want and that's what the
vikings can't do now even if they would
like to
okay but you know i don't know i haven't
lost faith in
mike zimmer i haven't you know again one
you apparently didn't watch the game
well you apparently were drunk on eggnog
well
i mean i might have been i mean that's
definitely a real possibility but
but it's it's pancake batter you know
he's he's
he first off it's not the gm they've got
salary cap issues they've been very good
i haven't lost
faith in in him i mean to where i
wouldn't
i would i would want mike zimmer back as
my head coach
right now i know he's still done so much
good
and this is a little bit of a transition
year i i understand but i still think
he's a damn good football coach i i
wouldn't give up i do too i look
i i i do too i i i just wonder what the
wolfs would do
if they hadn't extended him sure they
hadn't extended cousins
and if they hadn't extended rick
spielman would they extend them
now after what's happened this season
and again it gets back to my
theme and my theory the vikings just
good enough maybe they would just good
enough just be in contention it's just
good if you don't be great just be good
enough every year all right go ahead
yeah well i i hear you there you know
but i mean damn the offense is the
number six offense in football and maybe
if they can get some players on defense
this year
zimmer can get them back and maybe you
can jump on the bandwagon and be a
pretend vikings fan again well no you
never know
just all right shut up all right all
right
i gotta go to our game on sunday night
the packers titans game
you know two guys here two guys that i
think make critical mistakes
that really you know that dictated the
balance of the game
the first one it's six nothing rashaan
evans
who's leading football and personal
fouls this year
six nothing they're going to get off the
field it's going to be a three and out
or maybe a five and out whatever it was
against the green bay packers
they throw a screen pass he's down the
field not even a part of the play
but he's mad because david baccatiary's
blocking him and doing a good job
and therefore he sticks his hand up into
his face and face mask and grabs it
personal foul extends to drive touchdown
packers and then the other big moment to
me
and we didn't hit on this a lot
yesterday 1914
aaron jones down the sideline stepping
out of bounds
the fact that that never got challenged
and i don't want to blame total mike
vrable here
somebody's got to relay it to him to let
him know something there
i know i saw it in real time but that
was a huge moment in the game too
1914 he stepped out of the 39-yard line
and because it wasn't challenged they
had the ball at the six yard line that
was a big point and really
i don't think they ever recovered after
that last one for me jared goff
anytime a quarterback makes a throw that
i would never make
then he's a goat in a bad way and that
throw that was picked off by andre diggs
what the hell was i mean i still see it
and it's like what do you
what do you i don't know doing here i
don't know right
so sorry jared i know you hurt your
thumb and i know you had surgery and i
feel bad uh giving him a hard time about
it but he he deserves it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest
news and highlights from nbc sports